hello everyone so the first year
students of IIT kharagpur have just
arrived and I believe that across the
various other engineering Institutes of
India also the first students have
already arrived or are soon going to
arrive and I think this is a good time
for me to share a few tips with you so
that you can surmount some of the
biggest challenges facing you in this
first year of hostel life particularly
note that my tips will be focused on the
hostel life
all right
I think the biggest challenge that
students face in their first year
particularly if they have never stayed
in Hostel before
is not to realize that the kind of
routine which they had followed at home
during their plus two is not going to
work anymore okay it is just not going
to work
so what is going to work so when I say
like this immediately you may your mind
may go to uh the feeling that perhaps
you should follow the kind of routine
which some other students some more
experienced students I have already been
following perhaps looking at your
seniors or perhaps looking some of your
batchmates who have stayed already in
hostels as part of their coaching but
this also is a mistake okay you have to
realize that you have a certain unique
personality okay you have your own study
habits that you are accustomed to from
plus two
so if you suddenly and abruptly try to
change your habits you are going to fall
a flat in your face
okay so you're not supposed to do that
what you have to do is and therefore you
have to keep your eyes and ears very
open to your own feelings your own
Comfort level you have to find your own
uh through this keeping your eyes and
ears open you have to find the routine
which best suits you I know this is much
much easier said than done because uh it
definitely means that you have to go
through a process of trial and error
okay you just just cannot say that okay
such and such a routine is going to work
for me it is not you may try something
you may fail okay and the sooner you
realize this and the sooner you go
through this trial and process the
faster you'll be able to realize what
actually works for you what doesn't work
for you please also note that I'm
talking about this challenge as part of
your first year do not think that
whatever you feel and whatever you are
comfortable with in your first year is
going to stick through all the rest of
the three or four years of your college
life
okay so it may so happen that maybe
you're comfortable with a certain
routine uh
in your first year but that may no
longer be true as you grow older okay so
it is a very Dynamic process this
finding this best routine and and habits
which are suitable for you so you have
to be always always in this entire
journey of hostile life starting from
your first year you always have to start
adapting to the different changing
circumstances for example you may see
that some of the more experienced guys
they may have this habit of staying a
very late at night I mean they have fun
all through the afternoon and evening
and then
it is only at late at night that they
maybe do their assignments or maybe
study a little bit or whatever they they
need to do they do okay now if you do
not have that habit and you suddenly
abruptly you try to stay late at night
it is absolutely not going to work okay
your health will fail your the next day
will be a disaster okay so even if you
feel okay sometimes it may so happen
that the circumstance demands that okay
you have to go for some kind of a severe
change in your in your habits okay uh
for example uh there are a few students
who have the habit of during their plus
two while staying at home uh of waking
up very early in the morning and
studying that may not actually be
possible in Hostel life because if
everyone is awake at late into the night
and maybe they are pleasing playing some
loud music and these are realities of
host life okay maybe they are talking
maybe they are playing some loud music
how are you going to sleep early and
then how are you going to wake up early
which is why I always mentioned to my
students that when you are in college
life okay you have to find like you have
to be your own guardian and decide
things for yourself
you cannot okay you cannot listen to
your parents uh blindly especially if
your parents have never had the
experience of hostile life themselves
because with all due respect to uh to uh
to to parents uh it is a fact that
people who have never stayed in Hostel
life never really realize what actually
goes on in host life okay the next thing
is the next biggest uh
Big Challenge is is that sometimes
people just compare with on themselves
with others okay please do not compare
yourself with others like there is a
like a meme or a joke uh running in
India that your parents always compare
yourself with the hypothetical
sharmajika beta but there is actually a
truth in this joke so and it is true for
yours for you yourself also so when you
are surrounded by so much talented
people you will find that inevitably
there will always be someone who is
better at you than in studies better at
you in sports better at you in some kind
of cultural uh abilities like singing
dancing playing some kind of music
whatever okay they'll always always be
someone better than you and they'll
always be this like super talented guys
who are like multi-talented okay they'll
be good in academics they will be good
in music they'll be good in sports and
on top of that to make you even more
envious it'll also be very good looking
okay so if you always compare yourself
with others like there is no end to it
okay and mind you the most talented guy
he also if he allows himself this this
thoughts that uh he will or he or she
will compare themselves with others
they'll always always be someone in the
world who will be more talented more uh
I mean uh more capable okay so what is
the best route
the best route is always to compare
yourself with what you were yesterday
what you were in the previous Sinister
so my suggestion my simple Earnest
suggestion to all of you is that stop
comparing yourself with others just try
to keep getting better yourself whatever
you can achieve in this particular
semester in the next semester just try
to be better than that okay so over the
course of eight semesters and for the
Dual degree students over 10 semesters
if you can keep on improving on what you
have achieved in your first semester I
think it will be a grand Improvement it
seems rather silly to think of it like
this but I assure you many many students
have followed this philosophy and have
actually done very good for themselves
okay you also have to realize that
sometimes when you see some people who
are doing extremely well academically as
well as non-academically it is not
something that they have it is not that
they have suddenly become super talented
after coming to the iits or the nits or
any other college okay a lot of uh your
personalities have already been molded
or a lot of your abilities uh and
talents have already been molded and
honed back at school so perhaps somebody
has had the good fortune and privilege
of uh of being in a in a big
Metropolitan City and going to some of
the best colleges or best high schools
in India
then already he has he or she has an
advantage maybe in that school there was
some sort of training going on maybe in
music maybe in sports perhaps you have
not had that kind of a privilege back in
your school so he already he or she
already has that Advantage let him be
okay don't compare yourself with that so
sometimes it feels like
there are so many societies so many
events going on and uh are you always
expected to be part of all of these at
least three four of these societies it
is not like that so these various
Societies in in a campus are there
because it caters to the varied
interests the multifarious uh interests
of the various students okay Perhaps
Perhaps the only thing that you are good
at is to just maybe read story books
okay it may be possible you have no
other Talent you don't know how to sing
dance you don't even know how to play in
a musical instrument you only like
reading story books that's the only
hobby so just pay you so to speak you
have fine okay it is absolutely fine
do your studies do your actual academic
studies and find a little time to maybe
read even one book uh like in one month
that is good enough okay like you are
not beholden to anybody to show that you
have such and such talent okay if it is
not it is not there who cares okay so
please do not feel that you owe anybody
anything uh on on the non-academic front
Okay and mind you if you keep on
maintaining that even that little hobby
of yours reading story books you will
find that inevitably you will find
like-minded friends uh perhaps there is
already some kind of literary Society
perhaps you can write a little bit for
them and as you grow older into your
second year third year fourth year
perhaps you can join them okay and do
something which actually interests you
okay nobody is saying that you have to
be good in music and sports and writing
and all those things too just do one
activity which is not like which is not
fetching you monks and that is that is
enough
finally one of the biggest challenges of
hostel life is the loss of privacy so
people who have
who have spent the last two years at
home uh and we have never been part of a
hostel life uh so perhaps you are
accustomed to studying all alone in a
single room perhaps your parents were
able to provide you such kind of privacy
you closed your doors and just studied
all alone or maybe even not studying
just spend some time alone in your house
that may not be actually possible in
Hostel life
maybe you are you are I mean in most
cases it is true that you are going to
share your room with someone maybe from
some other state a completely different
personality from yours uh
and it is going to be difficult okay
nobody ever said that it's going to be
easy so these are actual challenges
which you have to face uh which will
actually help you to become an adult
at the same time if as I already said if
abruptly you you try to face this
head-on it may feel like a shock so my
suggestion is that if you really feel
completely lost completely like uh
detached from your own inner self
maybe what you can start doing is start
journaling journaling means writing a
diary maintaining a diary okay put down
your inner thoughts uh maybe maintain a
like a daily diary or even a weekly
diary that that should help a lot okay
plus ah
I think it is not always good to be
overly private okay because this host of
life is an enormous opportunity for you
to mingle with people from of different
personalities and these are the kinds of
situations which will never inevitably
have to face in a professional life
so when when I was in first year I I
faced this uh challenge that like if
somebody was sitting in front of me I
found it even hard to think properly
okay it was it I felt as if that person
was looking into my thoughts ah that is
of course a misconception but that is
what I felt but uh you see now in a
professional life you always have to
stand on your feet and think in front of
others okay that is absolutely a
requirement so try to train yourself and
get outside your comfort zone slowly
slowly okay but but as I said initially
you are going to feel it difficult but
but try to get used to this thing okay
it happens to many many of us
finally you may note that I have not
said anything regarding the at least not
much regarding the academics so I have
already made a video earlier about some
of the academic things about a year ago
I'm not going to repeat them here except
for one thing that please note that in
the semester system you are not going to
be able to learn the subject as they
should be okay like it is the rather
unfortunate thing about our semester
system that you actually end up learning
just courses not the subjects so
whatever your professor teaches the way
he or she teaches
you try to absorb that to the best of
your ability try to learn from the kind
of notes and the lecture materials the
exact lecture materials the specific
things which he or she wants you to
study okay please do not think that one
fine day you will open your book and
then study properly from it like you
used to do in your plus two okay that is
not going to happen that day will never
come
so on these uh on this note I think I've
shared some of the biggest challenges
some of the some of the tips associated
with the biggest challenges and I wish
all of you the very best as you start
your journey this this wonderful this
frightening journey of hostel life okay
all the very best to you I'll see you
around and people who are at kgp I
really will see you around literally
okay all the very best thank you